Efe o akşam mutfakta annesine yardım ediyordu.
Poşetten çıkardığı elmayı tartının üstüne koydu ve ekranda beliren sayıyı yüksek sesle okudu.
"200 gram."
Annesi gülümsedi.
Ama Efe'nin kafasında bir şey takıldı.
O gün fen dersinde tam da bunun üzerine konuşmuşlardı.
Kütle ve ağırlık aslında bambaşka iki kavramdı.
Efe elmayı avcunda çevirdi ve merakla düşündü.
İkisi gerçekten aynı şey değil miydi?
İlk durağa kütleydi.
Kütle, bir cismin içinde bulunan madde miktarıydı.
Elmanın içinde ne kadar madde varsa kütlesi tam olarak oydu.
Kütleyi ölçmek için eşit kollu terazi kullanılıyordu.
Bir kefeye cisim, diğerine birinen kütleler konuyor ve kollar dengelenene kadar ekleniyordu.
Kütlenin birimi kilogramdı.
Küçük cisimlerde gram kullanılıyordu.
Kütle değişmeyen bir madde miktarıydı.
Elmanın kütlesi kutupta, dünyanın öbür ucunda ya da Mars'ta da değişmezdi.
Çünkü elmanın içindeki madde miktarı hiçbir yere gitmiyordu.
Sıra ikinci kavramdaydı.
Efe elmayı bıraktı.
Elma tezgahan üstüne düştü.
Neden zıpladığında havada asılı kalmıyordu?
Her şey neden aşağı gidiyordu?
Dünya üzerindeki her şeyi merkezine doğru çekiyordu.
Bu çekim kuvvetine yer çekimi deniyordu.
Ağırlık kütleye etki eden yer çekimi kuvvetinin büyüklüğüdür.
Ağırlık teraziyle değil, dinamometreyle ölçülürdü.
Birimi newtondu ve kısaca "N" harfiyle gösterilirdi.
Ağırlık bulunduğumuz yere göre değişirdi.
Efe bunu anlamak için hayalinde bir yolculuğa çıktı.
Bir astronotun kütlesi dünyada tam 60 kilogramdı.
Astronot dünyada eşit kollu teraziye çıktığında,
terazi 60 kilogram gösteriyordu.
Dünya'da dinamometrede ağırlığı yaklaşık 600 newton ölçülüyordu.
Sonra Efe, uzay yolculuğunda Ay'a vardı.
Ay'ın çekim kuvveti, dünyanınkinin altıda biri kadardı.
Ay'da terazi yine 60 kilogram gösterdi, çünkü kütle değişmiyordu.
Dinamometrede ise ağırlığı yaklaşık 100 newtona düştü.
Bu yüzden astronotlar Ay'da dev adımlarla daha hafif hisseder.
Efe gözlerini açtığında, her şey yerine oturmuştu.
Kütle maddenin kendisiydi, değişmezdi.
Eşit kollu teraziyle ölçülürdü ve birimi kilogramdı.
Ağırlık ise gezegenin o maddeye uyguladığı çekim kuvvetiydi.
Dinamometre ile ölçülürdü, birimi newtondu ve bulunduğumuz yere göre değişirdi.
Elmanın 200 gram olan şeyi ağırlığı değil, kütlesiydi.
Efe elmayı bu kez bilerek ve isteyerek ısırdı.
Artık biri ona kütle ile ağırlık arasındaki farkı sorarsa, cevabı hazırdı.
Bir sonraki keşifte görüşmek üzere.
Merakla kalın, bilimle kalın.